wings I don't have wings the dark
crystal I have absolutely zero context
to be talking about this movie in any
practical terms this is not gonna be a
why it's awesome video you'll find out
why hey towards the back end nor is this
gonna be a nitpick rant
I don't consider puppetry to be the same
as animation it's not an animation
junkie but I just saw the Dark Crystal
not for the first time mind you but for
the first time on the big screen that
I've gotten to see it went with my
partner because one of her favorite
movies and I kinda want to talk about it
cuz there's is old stuff to talk about
if you've never seen the Dark Crystal
what it was is it was Jim Henson taking
the artistry in the mastery of puppetry
that he'd been working on and developing
and moving you know elevating with works
like the Muppets in Sesame Street and
bringing it to fully fleshing out a
fantasy world and the film is Stephen
still is unlike anything you have ever
seen it is staggering in how gorgeous it
is and just how it it looks it feels it
moves it is amazing now Jim has symbols
obviously the spearhead for this a lot
of people deserve credit Frank Oz has a
co-directing credit on it and Brian
Froud did the the concept art and heat
Froude would again work with Henson
later on the labyrinth and it's just
it's it's an astounding piece of work
there are no human characters in this I
was gonna say this don't human
performance that's not entirely true
because the longshots of some of these
are basically people with puppet heads
on so that they can you know climb rocks
and whatnot but like that if there's no
human characters every character is
primarily performed by a puppet and
there is very little special effect in
this there's like one or two shots that
have some compositing in them there's a
little bit
the very end but this is this is pre CGI
this is pre you know real good workable
green-screen
they had no cable removal did if the if
the rods or the cables or a performance
hand wasn't shot they couldn't get rid
of it they would have to start over so
that's what we're dealing with when
we're talking about the level at which
this thing was executed at and it it
really is just an amazing just deep well
I would argue that this is the most
complete fully realized fantasy world on
film basically until the Lord of the
Rings happened and I would possibly
argue might even be a more completely
realized world than even Lord of the
Rings is because even Lord of the Rings
they had to they found locations that
worked perfectly don't get me wrong but
they did find real places that you can
now visit the Dark Crystal is it's
almost all sets there's like one or two
long shots that are locations but it's
almost entirely sets you can't see this
anywhere except this movie it's it's
astounding I suppose I'll clarify
practical um fantasy world cuz I suppose
you could toss avatar out there because
it's all to do whatever as far as I'm
concerned that level of CGI it's just
animation not to belittle animation I
love it I'm getting off track so this
the the puppetry and this is a man all
of it is astounding the Skeksis probably
take the highlight because we get a
really wide range of them being gross
and scary and disgusting and funny and
they were they really run the gamut but
beyond that we have the Garthim soldiers
the way that they move and their legs
kind of they look like they're scuttling
they're really impressive the Mystics
are just amazing the Mystics really feel
they feel like they could be in a Star
Wars movie and and then you even have
more Muppet like puppets like the pod
wings like fizzgig and they still don't
feel like oh that's just a puppet in
this one they still feel like it work
so they managed to create a world with
these incredibly realized puppets that
feel like living breathing creatures and
yet can still get away with what is
basically just a furball with a mouth on
somebody's hand I don't know how they
pulled that off but they did and I could
go on forever about everything that
works in this I'm gonna try and
spotlight a few things I suppose I
should talk a little bit about the story
and and also clarify that later on I'll
be getting into spoilers I mean that
said it's the the plot is not such that
it has a lot of surprising twists and
turns it's a pretty standard hero's
journey plot um so if you're expecting
big twists you're you're at the wrong
place but it it is a you know there's
something wrong with the world here's
the guy who's destined to fix it there
he goes to go and try and fix it and he
is believed to be the Last of Us this is
Jen I'm talking about now he's believed
to be the last of his kind he runs into
another one of his kind when he meets
Keira you know they have a sidekick with
fizzgig they are being chased by
monsters the Garthim they're being
pursued at the will of the Skeksis you
know they have to try and restore the
crystal this crystal that cracked a
thousand years ago and that crack that
destruction made the world what it is
right now and so by fixing it they'll
change the world but and hopefully for
the better but we don't really know what
will happen when they do that so there's
a basic plot and it is very basic but
like you know I could I just need to
highlight some of this some of the stuff
that's in here I think the Skeksis are
the most impressive piece I mean the the
Mystics are gorgeous the Garthim are
great and there's some others that I'll
even mention but the Skeksis
first of all design wise are you know
they've got these bird heads and but
they're all unique they've all got
unique designs and those designs tell
you a lot about each of them just at a
quick glance you've got one that's very
much in the food and I was eating he's
got a slightly more scrunched up nose
you know kind of a look to him you've
got this one would let this monocle he's
the scientist and you know you've got
the the general who sort of takes over
when the Emperor dies you got the
Chamberlain who's
sneaky little bugger it's it's really
you get so much personality from every
single one of these which i think is
what elevates them over the mystics
because again I think the Mystics are
wonderful you realise but they're all
kind of interchangeable you can't tell
one from the other but with the Skeksis
at a glance like oh boy that one and
there's that one and there's this and
it's not like we get to know many of
them outside of the chamberland the
scientists the the general and there's
kind of like a one who's like a kind of
a second-in-command that's about it
there's a bunch of them that we just
kind of see but don't get much of a feel
for but they look so unique that they
get away with that and there's a ton of
little details like there's one of the
earliest shots I mean look this thing
opens with the crystal chamber for the
crystal that shot is so lingering and
loving and amazing to see on the big
screen I mean I'd only ever seen this
movie on home video up to this point but
to see that crystal chamber with that
music Trevor Jones music kick in and
these Skeksis moving about and even as
some of the credits go on you know the
the Crystal Eye
sends out beams and it locks in their
eyes and they kind of freeze but they're
not just completely still it moves
across each of them and they're like
they're like breathing parts of little
parts of them are pulsing I the the
general his eyes twitching and it's
these little touches that make them
alive and make them real and it's it's
so just stunning I mentioned the mystics
who are very they're kind of Yoda
they're all not so much in appearance
but certainly in plot function and in
terms of you know just the Zen nature of
them they fit that really well I
actually have a really soft spot for
Aughra who's this kind of weird prophet
sort of person you know she gives some
plot points later on she gives the
hero's object that that they need but
she's only got one eye which she can
take out and look around with and she
also has what is personally my favorite
line in the film which is she is told by
Genya
who send him in and it was his master
the wisest of the Mystics and she goes
where is he is he here no he's dead
could be anywhere then I love that fine
so much because it says so much about
her and possibly you know even this
world like can they hang around uh-huh
she certainly thinks they can and that's
fun regardless um so I I like her a lot
she's God she's bonkers
um I I'd be remiss if I didn't highlight
this one cuz this this is this is my
partner's absolute favorite character
that's fizzgig it's fizzgig he's just
this little round ball with eyes he
barks she's a bright but when he roars
when he gets upset the mouth goes from
this to this and it's all teeth and he
has this one moment of just weiming what
do you have told he needs to stay behind
he just goes oh my it's everybody in the
theatre cracked up at that everybody was
losing it laughing and it's awesome this
D is so much fun and he's he's the he's
endearing I think partly because he's so
small but he's also he's also brave at
the right moments but also kind of a
coward cause he'll roar at something and
then run away that's kind of his go-to
tactic but he is he is a great little
animal sidekick he works really well for
that
but you know I've been praising this
thing up and down left and right but
like I said this is not going to be an
entry of why it's awesome
and there's a pretty point of reason for
that I'll come to that there's a couple
of little stumbling points as it goes
along when I saw it in the theater it
actually came with a little sort of
thing ahead of it with Jim Henson's
daughter talking about the process of
making it and she mentioned something
that I think I'd read somewhere before
but I'd forgotten which was that
originally the Skeksis and some of the
other characters didn't have English
didn't have understandable dialogue so
the intent was that the story was clear
enough from the visuals you didn't need
to know what they were saying and it
turned out when they did their first
test screening that was now
true and as much as I said the snow the
story is very bare-bones which it is at
the same time there's just enough going
on in terms of how the structure of the
Skeksis work and one of the specific
reasons why they're doing what they're
doing
you do kind of need to know a little bit
more than you could get from just
unintelligible noises I mean like I said
the the plot is incredibly
straightforward but if you're actually
going to understand was the why of
anything in the motivations you do need
to have voice though so they went back
and had to write out a record dialogue
that would fit the mouth movements they
already had on film that were originally
just gibberish and I think and they did
pretty well at that but I think
something that they did is I think they
over compensated for the fact that
people didn't understand what was going
on because the the basic plot and the
set up gets explained and re-explained
and re-explained
Oh Lots across this movie and jen has
these weird internal monologue moments
that were very obviously tossed in
because like we should understand what
he's thinking a bit more but what he's
thinking isn't helpful that shouldn't be
there so they kind of they swung the
pendulum too far that said I'm sure it's
better as it is now than when you
couldn't understand what the heck was
going on but I think they over
compensated a little bit trying to be
really sure everybody got what was going
on that's honestly that's kind of a
minor thing though that's that's a
nuance to the storytelling that doesn't
impact the overall story itself all that
much but there's a really big problem
with this movie and I named it already
it's called Jen Jen is our hero he is a
gelfling and there's a number of
problems with him there's a narrative
problem with him and there's an
execution problem with him I'll start
with the execution because that's easier
to get past
so the gelfling it's him and Keira and
honest I think Keira works better I
think they just did enough with her face
that it was there or maybe it's just
because we don't have as many lingering
close-ups on her face that I felt like
it didn't look as off-putting but the
the fundamental part with the design of
the gelfling is Jen particularly is they
look
whoo human not that they could ever
possibly pass for anything other than
puppets but that's the thing you've
basically got an uncanny valley thing
going on where they look human enough
where the the ways in which they move
that aren't as fluid or as natural as a
human performer would be really stand
out and so like some of the stuff I
mentioned earlier where the Skeksis like
all the little touches like little
breath motions and you and the things
like that everything because those are
so clearly not human every little touch
you add like that makes them feel more
alive and the case of Jen is the
opposite because he looks so close to
human every little thing that you that
is missing just makes it stand out all
the more that this is a puppet and again
to make the comparison both the gulf
singing of the Skeksis they have these
really thin hands and their cable
controls so they're not there's no
there's not somebody's hand in there you
know working it where you know where you
can get full fluid movement it's cable
control which means they're a bit more
like this and when the Skeksis you get
away with that because they've got these
clawed bird hands that's fine but you've
got Jen's fingers that are supposed to
look like human fingers and they're just
sort of these mechanical movements and
it just it takes you it takes you out of
it you can't buy them and but honestly
that would not be so bad that would just
be a technical hiccup if it wasn't for
the narrative problems with this guy
which is okay I'm not gonna say that
prophecies and prophesied heroes and
destiny narratives never work sometimes
they do but as a rule I don't like them
and everything that I hate and
everything that can go horribly wrong
with a destiny narrative is embodied in
this one character I never liked Jen but
watching it this time it boggled my mind
how worthless he is as a character he is
a hero by narrative decree there is
nothing about him that actually makes
him the hero he doesn't choose to go on
his path you know he's given a quest by
his dying master he does
understand what he's doing he doesn't
understand why he's doing it he has no
personal motivation he doesn't even have
much in the way of skills so it's not to
be like a MarySue situation where it's
been determined he will be the best at
everything just so that he can complete
his quest no he kind of sucks at
everything and yet is still destined to
be the one to pull this all together
like you want to compare him to Kira
here is a way better character and I
actually I would be singing this thing's
praises if Jen had started out being the
one who's gonna fulfill the prophecy and
by the end it was Kira who did it
because all the prophecy says is that a
gelfling has to fix the crystal why are
we stuck with Jen okay but comparison
wise so Kira she knows the world she
knows way more about the world than he
does she can talk to animals she is she
is actively able to escape and get away
and hide she has wings she she saves
herself when she is captured so she
doesn't need him Jen there was a point
where Jen the the Garthim soldiers are
coming and tearing up this this town
this village and jen is literally just
standing there going he doesn't move
until Kira tells him to run oh man he's
used there's literally one thing okay
fine - there's two things that he does
one he identifies the correct crystal by
blowing into a pipe yay and two the
narrative has decided that he can read
and Kyra camp so he reads the prophecy
but we didn't even need him for that
because the prophecy gets explained by
his Skeksis about ten seconds after that
anyway so he's oh my god he's useless
and worthless and boring he's so bad
like there's absolutely no internal
reason why this character should be our
hero except that there's a prophecy and
he's the prophesied hero so here's your
hero like No I repeat jekt your prophecy
I reject your hero because he sucks and
it really is it's the it's the brick
around the neck of this of this film it
does not make the film not routine you
should because
is a stunning piece of work it's just
such a shame that were stopped like
every time we'd cut back to him to check
in on how our hero was doing I kind of
slump in the chair as good like we'd be
dealing with the Skeksis and you know
what was going on with with the
Gothamist they're tracking them down or
anything like that I mean uh huh and
then generally show up on screening and
just fine deal with you and it really is
a shame and I think Jen is the
overriding reason why for me I prefer
labyrinth I think if you're talking Jim
Henson fantasy works I think Dark
Crystal is the more impressive piece but
Jen just drags it down man he's he's no
good I mean thankfully things get better
once he's paired with Kira
because Kira is oh yeah I want to say
she's a better realize puppet that could
just be there aren't as many lingering
sauce on her like I said she's
definitely a better character regardless
so you know what she shows up with him
the movie picks up a little bit but man
god Jen socks and and that is a shame
because otherwise this is an astounding
film and if you have not seen it you
should see it and if you have the
opportunity to ever see a screening on
the on the big screen on a proper
theater screen do it even if you just
like I was pretty good no no no see it
it's incredible
so those are my thoughts on a completely
otherwise unprompted look at the Dark
Crystal I'm really glad I went to see
its money the little mini rant I went on
about its hero I had a really good time
at the theater with this one so the Dark
Crystal have you seen it what are your
thoughts about it whatever they are
drops coming down in the comments let's
talk about it there's all the stuff to
do support me on patreon buy t-shirt
Twitter podcast links for everything is
down in the description so until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]